This is a thought experiment.
Let's say at some point in the not-so-distant future
you're barreling down the highway in your self-driving car,
and you find yourself boxed in on all sides by other cars.
Suddenly, a large, heavy object falls off the truck in front of you.
Your car can't stop in time to avoid the collision,
so it needs to make a decision.
Go straight and hit the object,
swerve left into an SUV,
or swerve right into a motorcycle.
Should it prioritize your safety by hitting the motorcycle?
Minimize danger to others by not swerving,
even if it means hitting the large object and sacrificing your life.
Or take the middle ground by hitting the SUV,
which has a high passenger safety rating.
So what should the self-driving car do?
If we were driving that boxed-in car in manual mode,
whichever way we'd react would be understood as just that,
a reaction, not a deliberate decision.
It would be an instinctual panicked move with no forethought or malice.
But if a programmer were to instruct the car to make the same move,
given conditions it may sense in the future,
well, that looks more like premeditated homicide.
Now, to be fair, self-driving cars are predicted
to dramatically reduce traffic accidents and fatalities
by removing human error from the driving equation.
Plus, there may be all sorts of other benefits—
eased road congestion, decreased harmful emissions,
and minimized unproductive and stressful driving time.
But accidents can and will still happen,
and when they do,
their outcomes may be determined months or years in advance
by programmers or policymakers.